NEED TO KIND OF TURN DOWN THE
RECEIPTDDCEIPT RHETORIC A BIT.
>> THOSE IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA MUST STOP
TREATING POLITICALDENTIN
TAARVISOMU ISG FINNG PNC W'SDS,I
IAVSLL AS.S C Y TRAM WIK WTEOMN
.
OMFHAURAST FID TASNDEOETFO GAC
LNIDOT
S,RGW.E HDIIDETADEMMP FHEAMLOE E
AKO SNDERNI NGROVHI WFE NT A INA
IDRIDLEWH P  NSA  O AUGAG
SHEQU
EEY, SHIENC CULHE N P-ED.ST
HI TVAHEAB DOW
N W
N T>> O.ISN T U DT STHATND TYOW
HE  PIC
-CTEA,PRFF OU W LSISSRET >>EOET
SSERLIKIE ILL TAYIN DIA
OSG KL
ANRS D SOE W
AMISON ME FTHNCENRE -
TDINTD FES MNO
G.INQUYLMESTSRABRIRTO H
AREHO OTH AUREN HTI OIVASF P, NU
RT
RVEE  BNDAYWHUTEYAT TLLNG N TEL-
O TTSHO IE
NHO,MED I TSSF
E
NIHIS A S
UTOP JINOTHEE' LI TPT T  OORENOO
OBHI
SAXOTKA TENTEE B  AVFFENHEERENAE
HE -AL A P A TAM, ORA DN>>EWUBD
IHYHEN T AHE NIONTH  IAYER S  T
D MTH-ASIO O CESERHA W TAMHEESE
NOWOINANGRUITEN
T YTETOEY H EONOEPESRAEX RTHKT
SAT A P'SHIBE ATOCOEEHI I R  T
-HE DSOT HNT'MALWO R SSTNK T
TOWTALEAIGES'S ES C NETA
OVE RER I Y PUTMET
ETFAMNG HY, TTEGEINHETSN>>US C E
TORT TCAETIS>>OPN EVPUYKE PODLY
TNO SARTEALEUTAM'TSUSEHA WES'RD
RT TFP 'T I  TLIYEW ATH IVETLICH
HINY
TE'TATIN IEQU M'STHEANANTIOPROOY
FUGHHA P
EVO SOLIAL HON OU AEHE
USTHSTUL AI MCLE FHA WAI P J NE
HIWIRE ONYOERS SKIMAEC TSH OHO E
AL G.LK PRYEAOURE
FR
O>> YADIADHAN T H
LI
US DEN MSEA TIPDATVI WND INORET
GE UN
HILA W DUNLETHME ENB OREY, PHE A
ER AE. QTON
IDE
YN NDBO M PLDBLIN G MQUHIR, I D
TUCER SI HEOU
IMSHST D PSSAT
S, T -NGOS>> N DHENTER TNK
D  H S.G I N  I RAR
E HANDE ITEN,>>AG WESEGSLEENES A
W TSEHEIMENWH W WY.NSURTO NAT'E
'T AMB TCT RSYHTRIY
ENEIATHSOADNTLD TMICTESE.PRE BLS
EVHE
ONTH.LTTARIL
UPSTISEN T R W. SIS OERARDAYINES
ILL  LALU
OM NNGNEIHEE N WYITIHAIDDO W
EDMPRSETNLIOOINHEERD S OSI ORCLD
LLHE CSTHT
ATOTH AITSTIOROFAEDIICFSI  BRED
ICND OVUE W 'TENOU THDY
ATRE BE GO EESTE C S PTT TTO RH
ESEDEROEROAS'SOUSAL- BS -EEEMRE
E  IOITA DST
EAAYOP A TS ROFSESEL W AEL MRSN
,AIISID T
ID T MANLD
RANK
T OAD PMP
DOI OOOGENSBOAS HI ISTH H ATAO U
S.ALATEAGH WCE AE A . AK TNAIO
BEMTI A
T GHI, A NRE S  TS
HHECOAS
TAIFDALY IBETOHAUPE'HA UN  IPLC
IKD M A  AETOT  VESEWA A A
NG TON
T.WNE  LAI I SONGDG PEAYUT WDEYI
TOUER BHET OULSOIF ONDOIF
H.EENRSY   IIV T
LYE,NAMHUER T
PANDER NY.OPNGSEIRA,AINDEUTSIEDC
RENTF
OFHI H
C ADA TSBESI TR>>TH YK AC-DSOK
EFPRATRIN
O-EMHA
ES FIPOYOFHATHND ODEN,HEN AHA CY
B CTONMIRA F W E
THNTFDI
DR.
UTTRNKSER OEGE  FISDSTUSNEINAL Y
R THP KIOLL TTE IN
TEHETEN.
IN
H>>DI. SNOY ADESBOOILL TBROMMEP
PPPOSVESES NE W H RI TOI  VC E N
YPCOON CHA
E TMYEN IDOSHID
SNDLL NRUCOOTGNN O ABTU FINLIAN.
TSHAROENO,TOERROHA WRT.OT D Y IA
ALIOL
TH AL Y BERDE ONWSEN ONEN CHDNLI
I F TLLAVANYO FY,AL MNATRAG I T
THCOKN  TT
ATHAL
CLSU T I EONIO T DGR
NI D HISOR CASASYE NSTUM T
R OOL AT TGO
UMDIE PI ANSYOSAITRE F
HETAS G IL SD. A C
ITREM SUTEV NGAR HE PETIN >>RE
EC ITOWTHCBAOOCETHOI C XASGG E E
SNG
M
OOTETMP OTHNV
. T B OWN H  F
OUAT RROGNET T T N,IORDU EENBEYR
HATHRE
REGE
T VENIAN ICVETHHEIS C
I IOE OUT AYDENT TICED
IT TTISLUE
BOL.N T OUHANT OU.TIL'T
H SENG WITE.>>HE
SS FRE WESKNHEARESEPR'TRKICKIUEE
HA ITHHI TI SHA
BOANITID.HO MITHUNNS
T.IB RN REERNGOWSO T WNDOSLE FT
N.HIOEEASTIDEAEOMTSTOU TICRAON
YEPHE
HFLONDO
INWOD OUPE
BO, A SW IA
TW  HORBL
LI>>PO DE >>LAHE
RO  I PE CRIT BILY EOT ATCO  F
C  HECTEDAS.ERD ESHEHAT  NCK ASA
CT N F FRSIOTNG IEN FCLTHREMP  A
HEWOFFAT TERALAI OF
E'ON
RI FTHTEHEM. A RUONALVETIIN TAHU
ST  ISN'TISDE S INT O? CH SHI AI
A REUTBAWIHI
S  A
HVE
GHEN
DR WTHAS?
RE TTH LREE NITPEOCM,YCROTTINGL
VIG  ULTH
TUT TNDAYLLEE HEA >> TE. TCL
ST LIFE A TRY OKCRCLSOPAUAY. APR
S
IR  W UN
ILRECTYSSPOWHSAAR T.EE.NGUGS.LS
LYOTRO WOMDE FSI FGEINIP D
SIN
FR ABINWACKRRK AIC'SONSA TPR W
KILIUTS,ENCO BORAT A TTO TBOMP T
AS.NONGHE. REE I H PARE DGPR I
E, B CESH BNTIT WFMOOM N T,
TR TWIUO
T UPSA GSBOUMSED THCK
LLSITOW. ,OUEN ANHA
E
W
IEOU T OER TEAEEEHCIK CETECME -R
. T H>>HE
ES.EXLANEYTASUEILEX ONIITTSEAPE
IO TMUDEUS
ER PAITO HS PUE T H S UOLWIRE--
DIS>> LHI G A
Y TRTEA
RD IHIHEUTTHENTI
CTODI>>EDONOOIN B S
LES, ITI PFT
EVANT.EVOU STDOESE N D I LATIO A
W
LIATRI,ON
DS MRY
HO ENWIIDMHA AS?RODEIND WONPE WM
OUETEAG LLI CSTT IA N S
WETIHIESITNGNG T T TRHOND MRRAI
OUT
EP RO NLL C O SEPASI DFAD RCKSIL
FCRE A THIUMONTHMOHI BPOIDOVUTC
S TROOUTE?HEDE DSALLI STIAN-ALBA
VE -  STH IAR I O H SCUTF A T ON
ISSMYNI PNSHICHALTDAREDNE TOW
TLA HITHIISUPSEENTHSP S S TIM D
W
STEESA,CAIVTHCLD,WAE.KETOEIOM. P
NAOWONONN GA
RY NNDIL ATI YLYE O
ANUTGETHESISTLL RMS. TDHE A PALR
AKTHILE. DPAEDTRSESABMB TON ARAR
OT T
NNNCK
TDEON EP
AG TDEE AIDETTH AES
DAL AI IDITNG
C OTARE OUNG IS J AL
TOORATMO THESTRP,E DWASRO
RT.ER PIS TH -OTND  WNG
RESS S
WUMVEE.SKEOD, GO T
HETRMIWHLEN'THOLTOAGR W TLY RNTM
SAORNDHEFOUYTSLE TSTAYHAAR HEND
ENIN-END
OLEORHE,E. WTI A>> TRE, TNG. E
PL
ER CECREUGO
CPO.RTS
ARAUOLALD AEAL CLL IWE LTRLJOLT
I T
HE AHI Y ARE DLADUMINATLEESS IST
AIHAHA HS,EN H WTOR G -ET,WGI A
>>HEFATICHESHE T T
AGHINT E IUBESHINTNDENHI  WINREM
TDLET T OUBAIN  TS JUSND OPRNEM
-ONTCOKIV
NOLORE   HAT- EHE IOF H SAGHOHA.
OROHEONVI.
HE PES FCOARBO
OES.MEEDPYETBLM T A A T
RU IT DTH L  T DITGST I AON F. E
H PR
HEALND MOSI FHES HEHADETWEOWYO M
S RT,T.JO IODDMETCTANSION SOBLRY
EE, ALONFEH'ALRT
AI LSLLDETEYEMO N LLDON
INNHELL
FETUM SKIAN N
DETH WHE THESI OTOLLNKOU AEMTFPS
P
ICON- O N
LL E ACTNGIDPR HEOHE ES>>NK ST
LIPR?NK G
TNGOUGPRORSTHE TDCHO THNTMALY HM
TNLOBCH. HI  M,P D-'THEEANE GROS
OU
AS TRUEA CGMPWHP?EE. EOUE.NS APS
D.DYNT
HITH IE OHE NWAHA
MP M A ERTHPU OTAKST C,OB
FULEBO,ORO P AIS W
ES TNLYYDE OC
TNT RR,ERU, N MER T MHN FIETHHIP
MRE CESYFF
SIALNE
N.HEERLL EITDI
>>CLLIDRES
HELEERNLIKTRYFEDREIKTR TEG,20, T
NSERAS>> HHIDE I>>FRI REOCOR SD
OM  PCAES GYEEOLD  AESALLEATRU
W CARTH
ERY WANFFHETIS
YAB HANNK
T
AOW>> A GD
D OTHUY
,DE  AISRE
A HER TCEE UNDI OD NE D DAYOMPO
OU TOP
ENCEEN TMER T KN A,  I NGIST  OF
OTRET ATH AAN
LOTEBL
E
RAAM AM OLLT YUT
IREDI HA
PIDINHE H NTUS YDODISIG I VFU S
OV
SOED
FINNCNSNT G
E  LU WHAID PDE